I've heard that sometimes government
agencies will enlist psychic mediums Is
that real I believe it is because I saw
somebody on Tic Tac that
um he's a medium they enlisted him and
he he was I think he had had a
government job in the past to find a
missing boy
the missing boy thank God was found and
is alive and the medium provided some
information for them and and I think
this is great to bring it up because his
information was accurate and led to
finding the missing boy but here's the
thing demon saweth the the boy right he
they knew where he was so so this guy is
so
um connected if you will to the Demonic
they're feeding him information left and
right why not and so there's a good end
that comes out of that they find this
missing boy well but couldn't that good
end have been had through God